[Music]
nathan's with us in pensacola hi nathan
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave a long time listener i
appreciate your show and uh definitely
live by almost all the advice you have
well thank you how can i help
um so um my wife and i um
are looking at possibly buying a
property it's a little bit more
expensive than what i'm used to buying
so um
right now we own a home and we're just
trying to figure out if it makes sense
to uh take our our current investments
and just basically liquidate our current
investments and then
now uh go into debt with a mortgage that
would be probably about a three hundred
thousand dollar mortgage after we're
done with liquidating all of our
expenses all of our debt i'm sorry all
of our uh assets
okay how old are you
47 47 or 46. all of your assets you mean
you're pulling retirement out
no no no um the retirement i can't touch
until uh later but we've got um
listening to you guys like uh smart
investor kind of stuff and uh we went
with
a smart investor pro here in
pennsylvania that's cool so you have how
much money in investments that are
non-retirement
um
probably about uh 600k total
okay
and your current residence has how much
equity in it
about 400
okay
so you're buying a million three house
it's going to be a little bit less than
a million three but it'll be a little
over a million
okay i missed how you get three hundred
thousand dollars in debt because i got a
million dollars here 600 and 400.
so
i guess uh
the mortgage might not be quite 300 um
it'll be probably closer to 200. when we
uh
when you have all the closing costs and
everything into it
okay so you're talking about you're not
going to net 400 out of your house
well we should we should net 400 out of
the house
and you have 600 in investments
and savings and everything yes that's a
million
and the house is a million
there's not 200 000 in closing costs
there's not a 20 closing cost there's no
such thing
[Music]
so i guess it's just kind of an uneasy
feeling going with a higher home value
and just i guess the biggest that i have
is does it make sense to liquidate the
uh the investments that we have right
now i wouldn't buy the house if i didn't
because you're going to go into debt so
it's the same question of if i had a
paid four million dollar house would i
go borrow 600 000 on it to put money
into investments
no i wouldn't
not taking the money out of the
investments and putting them on the
house is the same thing as borrowing on
your house to do that so you should not
buy the house unless you're willing to
use the investments to do it what's your
household income
uh right now it's probably about 110.
and how old are you guys
48.46
will you be able to afford the taxes on
a million dollar property at a hunt with
a hundred thousand dollars a year just
to just to maintain the property keep
the lights on this thing keep the yard
mode
uh yes we will
yeah um florida's got some generous
disabled veterans uh tax benefits
okay so why do you want to buy a million
dollar property
it's something my wife and i have always
dreamed about living on water and uh
this is an opportunity to do so right
now
okay
i don't think you're gonna need a
mortgage or if you do it's a very very
small one and you're going to turn
around and get that paid off as fast as
you can if you're sitting in this
property debt free
within a couple of years then i'm fine
with this idea
if you want to do it
the thing that's out of balance that
you're feeling is is that um the vast
majority of your net worth is now tied
up in your single-family home
that does not that does not generate an
income
it does grow in value but it does not
generate an income and so um you know
you're going to have to really pour on
the coals and build some investments by
the fact that you don't have any house
payment in the near future
to make this work but no you don't need
a 300 mortgage the numbers you keep
giving me that you act like they add up
and they don't add up
i mean 600 and 400 is 1 million and you
buy a million dollar house for a million
dollars and you use a million dollars
you shouldn't have a mortgage
and so
this makes me uncomfortable like it
makes me uneasy that's a lot of the
reason is that all everything you own is
going into this house
except your retirement
and uh it is it's out of balance it's
too much really yeah uh but if you're
paying cash for it i think you can
tolerate it as long as you turn around
and start dumping money into retirement
really really quick uh would i do this
if i were in your shoes no i wouldn't
yeah
no i wouldn't maybe that's what i
wouldn't either because i don't want
that much of my net worth
making a hundred and ten thousand
dollars tied up in a single family house
that does not create income
and i'm thinking of it
if the air conditioner goes out on this
million dollar house
it's going to be an expensive repair or
if the driveway needs to be or if i got
to do some plumbing work
it's all so expensive
everything i mean 100 of the houses
break yeah yeah 100 of them need crap
done to them and um brand new no matter
who built them no matter where they are
i mean i'm a lot of real estate and
there's just uh they they eat money yeah
so you're put to your point that's good
yeah i think i i you know the more i sit
there and talk this through listening to
john too
i'm risk-averse though so let me say
that but i mean i i
there's just no margin here there's no
there's no way i keep coming back to
march there's no wiggle there's no
wiggle room
one of you gets sick or whatever you get
something life goes sideways yeah now
you got a lot of wiggle room with 600
thousand in the bank
so probably what i would do is take your
600 and pay off your current residence
uh which you should have done anyway if
you're listening to me but that's that
part where you said you just did part of
what i teach i remember that part i
didn't drive by it i heard it
and um
then
then i would save like a crazy person
and i might do this deal in five years
where i've got 500 000 left over
after i buy it now that started if you
had 500 000 left over non-retirement
after you move in there
you do a million dollar house 110 000
incomes is is low for a million dollar
house but
if you're paying cash for it for
whatever reason it's okay but you do
need some liquidity
and it doesn't need to be
freaking 90 of your net worth that's
just that's out of balance or can you
save up some money and and go
multiple weeks instead of lake house a
year and i mean
i don't even mind if you buy you know if
your dreams live on the water i agree i
like living on the water i've got i've
got properties on the water i like it
but um water water is amazing yeah but
the uh but but it's not amazing if it
steals your piece instead it gives you
peace
so and there's no margin here no margin
it's dangerous that's a dangerous deal
no i wouldn't do it i'm gonna retract i
wouldn't do it because i don't like the
fact there's no wiggle room what i would
do is i pay off my house today
and i'd start saving like a crazy person
and make this a three to a five year
dream
and just keep piling up cash and keep
investing with a paid for house but
you're going to do what you're going to
do because you already don't do some of
the stuff we teach so that's up to you
you get to decide but that's
that's what i would do if i woke up in
your shoes
um
i find people don't have margin with
their time they don't have it with their
relationships they don't have it with
work they don't have it with money we
just have a margin free society now man
well they just it um there's friction at
greats the get frayed ins yeah
and you get frayed at the ends and it's
just um because everything's pushed to
the edge
and it takes what would have normally
been a blessing
and and
you you know you add two doses of stress
to it and all sudden you don't the thing
you're supposed to be in love with you
hate and when you think of it uh
psychologically our brains were designed
to to run at that level when a lion was
chasing us not to live like that
it just rattles everything to our core
you know it's a big old house with a
lion chasing you around inside that you
just parked the line in the front yard
yeah that's right so we've already
deteriorated tiger king right here this
is the ramsey show